حدث في اخر خطاباته اقطاب الصناعه
العسكريه الروسيه على زياده الانتاج
مطالبا للمجمع الصناعي العسكري للاستفاده
من الخبرات المكتسبه من الحرب لتطوير
ترسانه موسكو
الصفه الابرز في الحرب القائمه في
اوكرانيا هي الاعتماد على الطائرات مسيرات
كالكلاشنكوف روسيه روسيا كذلك لجات الى
التصنيع الايراني الرخيص للحصول على
المسيرات المفخخه لضرب البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه
لكن لدى موسكو اسلحه اكثر تطورا تستخدمها
ضد اهداف مهمه كما اقر القياده والسيطره
ومخازن السلاح الاوكرانيه كالصواريخ
المجنحه كاليبر التي يتراوح مداها بين
1500 كيلومتر اما اوكرانيا فاعتمدت على
مسيره بيرقدار التركيه في بدايه الحرب ثم
توالت عليها المساعدات من حلفائها
الغربيين فحصلت على سويتش بليد
وفينكسن ستدخل منظومه الدفاع الجوي
باتريوت لساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا
العربيه